hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we're going to be diving into a
brand new series that has recently taken
the anime community by storm i've
absolutely loved getting into the series
and writing the hype train that twitter
is on every single week then an episode
releases now and of course this is the
extremely cute and heartwarming yet
still somehow exciting and thrilling and
action-packed world of spy x family in
this first video we're going to be going
over the first full arc of the series
the introduction arc throughout this arc
here we are introduced to our
protagonist of this story the
wonderfully perfect man that is the
master spy twilight we learn of his
mission called operation strokes which
is to maintain the peace between the two
countries of where starlis and austania
however along the way he runs into some
completely unforeseen situations they
make for some absolutely awesome
interactions if you do want me to cover
more of obviously spy x family story
then do be sure to let me know down in
the comment section below and try to
push this video to 2 000 likes so i know
you're all keen on the next part also if
you are interested in more anime content
just like this where i explain full arcs
and stories then make sure you hit that
subscribe button as well but anyway
enough of that let's get into this dope
ass world of spy x family
[Music]
after the death of one of their
diplomats in a car accident in austinia
the heads of westalis met to discuss the
situation they believe it wasn't an
accident but an assassination by the
east's far-right political party
believing that they plan war against
westarus one of them suggests that they
see their best agent twilight
elsewhere a man provides proof that the
foreign minister wears a toupee a
disguised man takes the pictures stating
that he can now force him to resign then
leaves in a car a moment later though
the real person edgar comes to take the
pictures causing the first man to
realize that he was played that evening
twilight is out on a date with karen
which is like honestly perfect person to
start complaining and she literally does
she starts complaining that her father
was in a bad mood since someone had
stolen pictures she then sees a man
proposing to a woman and wonders if
they'll ever get married as well but
twilight interrupts her stating that
they should break up as he doesn't sense
any intelligence in her good old twyla
and his trillionaire grindset only
apologizes in his mind after obtaining
these pictures as he has no use of her
anymore he throws away his disguise
stacy he got rid of marriage aspirations
as well as his identity the day he
became a spy the next day twilight
receives a newspaper containing
information about his next mission they
congratulate him for the success of his
last mission and explain that his new
mission involves the leader of the
national unity party donovan desmond
toilet needs to get close to him and
probe any revolutionary activities but
in a complete twist to complete this he
will need to get married and somehow
have a child this is because donovan is
a cautious man who only appears at
social gatherings held at the school his
son attends twilight will need to enroll
his child there and infiltrate the
gatherings as the deadline for the
enrollment is near he only has one week
to somehow pull this off but even still
he ends up accepting the mission
later twilight goes out looking for a
family apartment after inspecting it and
finding that it has good escape routes
he decides to take it he signs the
documents as lloyd forger a psychiatrist
he then visits an orphanage and because
the man there was a drunk who doesn't
care he tells him to take whichever
child he wants which is honestly kind of
sus dude like you don't want your
orphanages just given away kids twilight
then states he prefers a child that can
read and the man points out at anya
while looking at her twilight thinks
that she needs to be older than sex
randomly anya then states that she is 6
years old twilight thinks that she is a
bit short though but then anya
immediately tries to make herself taller
standing on her tabby toes she then
takes a crossword and as twilight starts
solving the crossword puzzle in his mind
anya listens then hands him the
crossword all solved leaving him
completely and utterly surprised he then
gets excited she would pass the exam
easily deciding to take her however in
reality anya is actually a telepath who
is able to read his thoughts and gets
excited at the idea of being in on a spy
mission heading home twilight tells her
that she must say she was always his
daughter entering the apartment anu
turns the tv on and sees spy wars
stating that it's her favorite show
having to forge an id for her twilight
says that he has to go out but anya
decides to go with him while out anu
gets overwhelmed and between the crowd
and a completely random chick tells
twilight to keep a hold of his daughter
holding her hand twilight thinks that it
will be hard for him to prepare for an
enemy attack and because anya is able to
read his mind she starts panicking and
goes to hide but to achieve his mission
twilight thinks that he must start to
understand her and build a good
relationship hearing these thoughts anya
states that she likes peanuts and crispy
bacon pointing out at a sign but
twilight corrects her that is a bakery
instead and that they do not sell bacon
anya attempts to buy a spyware's poster
with a 10 pen coin but the shop owner
states that it costs 1 dalek which is
the currency of this world don't know if
i said that right but i hope i did
saying this twilight starts to wonder if
she's actually stupid and should take
her back for another child anya though
instantly starts crying asking him to
not get rid of her as she causes a
saying he offers to buy her peanuts and
she instantly calms down before heading
home he ends up buying some books about
child raising the next day twilight
wants to see how smart anya is but she
refuses to study annoyed he goes out and
demands that she stays home yet as
expected anya still attempts to follow
him getting caught each time that she
tries to escape
in order to keep her home he ends up
barricading the front door to the house
later twilight meets with frankie
franklin which is another dope ass name
and explains why he was late frankie
gives him an application ticket for the
exam and exam questions he then gives
him all the information he could find on
anya but the only info is from the last
year where she was adopted four times
and later returned each elsewhere at the
house while bored anu recalls that
twilight locked all of his spy equipment
and goes to play with it finding a
transmitter she sends a hilarious
message that she is the infamous
twilight and mocks them for trying to
find her returning home twilight notices
that the front door's barricade isn't
like he left it entering inside he gets
ambushed but manages to beat all of the
men unable to find anya he believes that
she has been kidnapped and it's due to
him being compromised while thinking of
running away a man suddenly attacks him
from behind knocking him unconscious the
men bring anya to edgar stating that she
was in the room where her message was
transmitted edgar wonders if she is
twilight's child but decides to use her
as a hostage to make twilight steal the
toupee off of the foreign minister one
of the men suggests that they give up on
their toupee but iggy shoots him
explaining that transparency is
essential in government and that their
minister is a traitor the rest of the
men having captured twilight return
edgar then removes the bag from his head
but sees his man nuang and that the fake
nuang is gone along with anya as
twilight runs with anya she starts
crying though twilight recalls that he
probably hates kids crying because it
reminds him of his own past where he was
alone and helpless able to only cry
after getting out of the building he
gives her a note and tells anya to run
to the police he doesn't think he is a
failure as a spy but made a huge mistake
to put a little girl in danger and
regrets forgetting that he became a spy
in order to create a world where
children won't have to cry
twilight returns to the building and
sets up traps then his edgar's men come
they activate the traps releasing flour
everywhere throughout the room using
this to the advantage twilight takes
them on one by one he then points a gun
at igga's head and asks him how karen is
making edgar wonder how he knows the
name of his daughter toilet explains
that he is a spy and knows everything
continuing to threaten edgar to leave
him alone if he wishes his daughter to
have a normal life
walking out of the building twilight
sees anya waiting for him as she comes
to him he acts like he doesn't know
anything anya explains she played tag
with some old guys but it was scary and
wants to go home recalling how she was
returned each time after the adoptions
toilet agrees and takes her but explains
that they might have to change
apartments as they found a bloody snake
in theirs later on and on the day of the
exam anya tries to read the minds of the
other kids but they're all panicking as
none of them know the answers she then
remembers what she had studied with
twilight and writes it down after the
exam he and anya look at the board with
the past students and twilight sees anya
on the list as he relaxes all of his
exhaustion suddenly hits him making him
fall onto the ground
at home twilight is passed out on the
couch when the mailman comes anya tries
to give him the letter but as he doesn't
react she ends up cuddling in right next
to him twilight then wakes up surprised
that he ended up falling asleep in front
of someone anya then gives him the mail
and reading it twilight learns that the
second phase of the admission process is
a family interview needing a wife for
the interview twilight calls frankie and
dresses him up as a woman yet he doesn't
like the result frankie complained
stating that twilight could have done
better but he explains that this is the
best he can do with what he has to work
with recalling the mission twilight
decides that he has no choice but to
actually look for a wife at berlin city
hall camilla gossips that a thief may
have entered the office but had only
searched the drawers with the
information about the girls however mali
finds the chief to be hella creepy as he
always gives her the [__] look if you
know what i mean sharon states that it's
due to the short skirts millie always
wears but millie explains it's because
her boyfriend likes them they then see
your making coffee for the section chief
and they suggest adding boogers but your
wonders if that would actually make the
coffee taste better seeing how cracked
she actually is they comment that the
guys are probably staying away from her
but still she has a nice body and face
so if she happened to use better clothes
and makeup she will be quite attractive
yora is fine with her job but camilla
points out that she is 27 years old and
single and with the increase in spies
people have started reporting anything
that is a tiny bit suspicious including
a recent case where neighbors reported a
single woman in her late twenties
camilla states she's having a party this
weekend and invites your to come with a
partner later that night euro receives a
call from her brother yuri he's slightly
worried about her since she is kind of
odd yuri explains that there is a slight
chance he will be promoted and become
even busier but he is worried about
leaving his sister alone he suggests on
introducing her to someone yet she
explains that that wouldn't be necessary
as she is going to a party this weekend
with her partner yuri is surprised that
she actually has a boyfriend however
hearing that it's camilla's party yuri
explains that he will be asking dominic
about what type of guy yo is dating and
if he happens to be some sort of loser
yuri will chase him away as she hangs up
you'll wonders on what to do if yuri
finds out she lied he will lose even
more trust in her the phone then
suddenly rings again and your rushes to
pick it up she tries to immediately
explain to yuri that she was joking
however it's just the shopkeeper who
states that she has a client for the
thorn princess at royal hotel room 1307.
you're then heads to the hotel and on
room 1307's floor the guard tells her
that the floor is reserved however your
states that she has heard that there are
traitorous scumbags that are there she
then pulls out a blade and kills the
guards entering the room she explains
that she is actually there to kill the
vice minister brennan in a crazy turn of
events she proceeds to kill everyone it
is explained that she is actually an
assassin with the code name thorne
princess who has been taught since a
young age as she washes the blood off
she sees that she has ruined her only
good dress and states that the only good
homemaking skills she has are cleaning
elsewhere he gives twilight all copies
of files of unmarried woman from the
city hall finding a woman who doesn't
care he is divorced with a kid is
refined enough for a prestigious school
and willing to get married within 48
hours will be a miracle anya wonders if
a child is a problem but twilight is a
straight shooting legion and assures her
that it isn't telling her to go watch tv
instead frankie wonders why twilight
doesn't use a female agent from his work
but twilight states that he couldn't
find a good match as they don't have
enough agents currently twilight also
has another mission where he needs to
eliminate a certain smuggling ring while
going over the files for this ring
frankie suggests the fastest way would
be to find a woman with bad
circumstances who will cooperate with
them but twilight wishes to avoid any
risks frankie then points out that anya
is risky herself as she doesn't look
rich agreeing with that twilight then
decides to buy anya some new clothes
later on while anya is getting measured
at the tailor toilet recalls the files
of some of the woman there suddenly your
passes behind him bringing the dress she
ruined now wanting it fixed twilight
recalls her file a single woman with
both parents deceased and a younger
brother both working as civil servants
with clean records you'll notice that
twilight had been staring at her and
asks him why initially surprised hidden
states he was actually admiring her
beauty
hearing that he likes her and also
needing a partner your thinks about
asking him out but anya then returns and
seeing here as a child your backs off as
she heard that women have been killed by
wives for trying to steal their husbands
reading her mind though anya learns that
your is actually an assassin which gets
you super excited she then reads
twilight's mind finding that he was
considering your for a wife and also
reading your's mind that she was
considering twilight for a partner but
is now backing off anya then starts
acting and saying that she's lonely
because she has no mother yore then
wonders where twilight's wife is and he
explains that she had died two years ago
learning that y'all decides to ask him
to be her partner to a party she
explains the situation with her brother
and twilight agrees however he then
explains his situation and admiring his
opposed morales your agrees too the two
then agree to me again at saturday's
party later on while shopping twilight
receives instructions for his other
mission deciphering it he learns he
needs to retrieve stolen art pieces and
eliminate a smuggling ring he must carry
the mission out at 1800 hours on
saturday when the target meets with the
buyer skipping forward and now on
saturday he decides to take frankie with
him to finish the mission faster and
still be able to attend the party yet
frankie is against it because he is
terrible with the hands however twilight
states that there are 78 pieces of art
that are worth millions and no one would
have noticed if one or two pieces go
missing hearing that frankie gets
motivated and agrees to go
during the mission they managed to
retreat alone
there yur apologizes to everyone for
being late and that her partner wasn't
able to come the woman gossip though
that they were sure her boyfriend didn't
even exist dominic is sorry that he
couldn't meet your's boyfriend and she
asks him if he can tell her brother that
he was actually a kind gentleman however
camilla the complete [__] disagrees and
states that she will make sure that yuri
learns that she came companionless yor
then sits alone looking at the crowd and
guessing that this is what a normal life
is the woman gossip that she had the
nerve to even come alone and still sit
there hearing that joe decides to leave
but in that moment our goat and shining
armor twilight finally arrives as he
bleeds he apologizes for being late and
introduces himself as lloyd fordeur
joe's husband accidentally mixing his
intermission lloyd explains that he's a
psychiatrist and one of his patients had
a violent episode camilla is surprised
to hear that jorah is married and
wonders why she hadn't ever said so
lloyd explains that it was probably hard
to bring up as it's his second marriage
and he is a child from the first one
camilla though gets angry not wanting to
believe that your actually has a
handsome husband wanting to embarrass
her instead camilla takes the hot gratin
and acts as though she tripped over and
throws it at you you're though stunts on
her dumb ass and manages to capture the
plight with her feet
lloyd then admires her dedication to not
waste food but points out that she must
not use her feet to catch the plate
camilla then tries to tell lloyd that
you did some questionable work before
working at the city hall where she was
called into hotel rooms to give massages
but obviously that was a cover-up for
her assassinations she attempts to
explain it to lloyd but he interrupts
her saying that it was wonderful lloyd
then explains that you lost her parent
at a young age and did everything to
care for her younger brother and having
to sacrifice herself for someone else
requires an incredible amount of
dedication lloyd and your then leave
with our boy apologising for saying that
he was her husband the van suddenly gets
attacked by some of the remaining
reinforcements which causes lloyd to
wonder there was a tracking device in
the art pieces he explains that some of
his patients still haven't recovered
from the psychotic episode they leave
the van and lloyd manages to knock out
the two men explaining that he is using
a concussive recovery method two more
men attack lloyd and he manages to knock
the first but as the second was about to
hit him yo knocks him out she apologizes
for helping with the recovery and that
she is actually a self-defense expert
they continue to run and defeat more men
and as they do so you'll suggest that
they should actually get married euro
explains that she is considered
suspicious for being single and they can
remain together for both of their sakes
lloyd agrees and wishes that they go to
the city hall right away to get their
marriage confirmed looking for the ring
he realizes his pocket has a hole and
had lost the ring then as more men
appear the duo dive behind cover
cheekily lloyd takes out a grenade and
throws it at them and at the same time
he uses the grenade's ring to propose to
your and she happily agrees
[Music]
so that officially brings us to the very
end of the first part of spy x family
story which is i'm not gonna lie bloody
awesome and i'm super super duper
excited to be able to actually get into
the story here and obviously the next
arc has actually already been completed
by the anime so i'm going to get into
that in the next video for spikes family
which i don't know when it'll be out but
it'll be out in the up and coming weeks
for sure obviously i've got like other
series that i want to try and complete
in the meantime as well so i am working
hard on those and i've got a bunch of
other content that is going to be coming
out in the meantime as well that isn't
like story based stuff but more like
explanation based stuff if that makes
sense but yeah either way i hope you
guys have enjoyed the video and if you
are new and here i want to watch more
stuff just like this but like other
anime series or perhaps even more spikes
family stuff in the future hit that
subscribe button and let me know down in
the comment section below and also you
know make sure you try and get the video
to 2000 likes so that i know you guys
are super super like kane obviously on
more spike's family but anyway for now
it's been your professional degenerate
tivolu and i will see you all in april
bye
[Music]